it is all about family and food for Neil
Patrick Harris and his husband David
Burtka yeah David has a new cookbook out
now called life as a party so we had
Neil take the reins as the interviewer
and watch what happened my name is Kevin
Frazier and I'm gonna be asking you a
couple questions on behalf of the show
thank you Kevin
nice try Neil so how well do these two
proud dads two eight-year-old daughter
Harper and son Gideon know each other
who is the most helpful sous chef in the
kitchen I have to say Harper that's not
that's not the correct answer
I mean between the two children or you I
mean it's your job just to do the dishes
so yeah my job one celebrity you are
dying to have over for a party police
say Shawn Mendes please Jason Mendes
police station Nick Jonas or Shawn
Mendes great answer
I mean we had Oprah over for pizza I've
who gets to say that by the way we had
Oprah over for pizza while we may never
have Oprah over for dinner David says
his book will make anybody a fabulous
host it really was something I really
wanted to do because I really loved
creating special moments for people I
have one final question for you where
are the children
the children
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]